- Hi my name is Claire.
Do a little dance.
Terrible!
I hope what my YouTube videos have done
is help people realize that they can be
a normal human being.
They can be whatever
the hell they wanna be,
and be sick.
I don't think that I've lived
any less of a beautiful life
than your average healthy Joe.
My name is Claire Wineland,
and I have cystic fibrosis.
Cystic fibrosis is a genetic disease,
both terminal and progressive,
which means that as you get older
cystic fibrosis gets worse.
And it's also terminal, which
means that downward hill
will end, in death. (chuckles)
When I was born, my life
expectancy was around 10 years old.
So then life expectancy was
pushed to 18, and then 19,
and now mid to late 20s.
I realized a lot of people
with CF are really ashamed
of having CF.
It doesn't have to be like
this dark hidden secret
that you're dying.
On my YouTube channel
I've covered stuff like
what it's like to actually be in a coma,
how to talk to people who are sick,
what not to say to people who are sick,
stuff like that.
Sorry this was so depressing.
Here's a little joke to make it better.
What is, (clears throat)
the biggest downside of
sudden unexpected death?
Being unable to delete
your search history.
Trying to explain how
cystic fibrosis feels
without sounding like
you're being overly dramatic
and depressing is hard.
It really feels like you
have sand in your lungs,
and overall you just feel heavy and tired.
My friends say I'm like a
grumpy old man. (laughs)
And it's interesting looking at,
you know, the way that other
people live their lives,
which is, you know, they've never
really had to think about death.
That's never been a
constant in their life.
So I think fundamentally
at the end of the day,
it doesn't matter really
whether you're scared of death
or whether you're scared
of paying your bills,
we all have things in our life that are
just completely foreign.
That's the reason that death is so scary
is 'cause it's so foreign.
I think I want people to
take away from my life
the notion that,
they can live lives that they're proud of,
whether or not they think
their life is normal.